state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covet 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67
and the governor's emergency order 12
pursuant to executive order number
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically this is a
committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
the meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order emergency order i
am confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and that the public has he is
listening contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
of this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91-a anyone who has a problem
accessing this meeting should call
271-3600
or email yes
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff on the
that are on the meeting
assisting us right now we have jennifer
four who was our committee researcher
uh joel retired um and please note that
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each meeting states
their presence please
also state whether you're whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during the meeting which is required by
the right to know
law for this purpose i'm going to ask
representative reid to call the role
you're very quiet oh there we go thank
you mr chair although i can see
uh everyone's names i'm going to call
the roll while i take
notes uh please correct me if i refer to
you
or mispronounce your name um incorrectly
uh
representative tim lang representative
lang is here
i'm in new hampshire my youngest son
timothy
is juniors running around being
homeschooled
uh representative abu khan
representative james spelaine i am
present
and i am in deerfield new hampshire and
i am alone
representative raymond howard
representative howard
did i hear a thing hello
there you are representative howard are
you alone
uh well i'm not really
i'm down in my game room okay
my family's upstairs okay
uh represent uh this is really breaking
up bad for me i mean
i have terrible internet so excuse me if
i
miss some stuff representative kevin
craig
i'm here at my home in lancaster my
son is in the living room around the
corner
wife and daughter are through the house
and the bedroom
they might be able to hear but no one's
listening
uh representative david love i
am here i'm in derry i'm alone
representative dan wolfe
i am here in noland new hampshire in my
office
and i am alone representative
mack kittredge
representative kittridge
representative donald dusty
holbrook there's a contractor in the
house and that's it
representative jonathan smith
president and home alone representative
catherine harvey
i'm here in spafford i'm in my office
alone but my husband may wander through
at times
representative larry laflame i'm
president and i'm all alone
representative roger dottonville
i am present here in enfield and my wife
is in the house and she may occasionally
walk through
representative mark king
i'm here alone in the house except for a
rabbit and a cat
and my partner may walk through in about
an hour
representative denny ruprecht i believe
he is
uh not going to be attending
representative steve shirtless
you're muted steve
i think i sound better muted anyway
i'm at my cabin in bethlehem and i am
alone
representative donna ellis i'm
here alone in my house in rochester
representative ariel oxel
i'm present i'm alone with the dorsha in
my office my husband is in the other
room
and uh representative ellen reed is
myself and i am present
i am not in my home in newmarket i am in
bretton woods
in a public space in a hotel and uh i
don't know who may come through the area
and i believe we are also i am going to
be
recording the presence of the acting
committee researcher gen 4
has anybody else attended the meeting
since roll call has been called
we have a member of the public with a
step and i don't know if jen wants to
handle that and
see why they are raising a hand or what
have you
that's up to representative lang if
you'd if you'd like to
look into that or we can not
uh let's get continue with the
orientation portion we get into
right before we start the fish and game
presentation we'll
take up whatever the public might have
there okay
so this year we have a little bit
different format as everybody sees being
remote
um one of the things that's going to
necessitate is a new committee
appointment and all the committees
will be appointing a committee
technologist this year as well
with just moving the meeting along and
helping
members with any any uh issues and
promoting
promoting panelists um so i also be
appointing a committee clerk
as well um so for this term i'm
appointing
um representative ellen reed as our
committee clerk
and i'll be appointing representative
james lane as our committee technologist
any questions about those two
appointments
and what their roles are
great there being none um i'm i'm gonna
get
let's jump right into the mission game
everyone's time is valuable
and we want to get the uh presentations
uh done in case we run over with
questions i'd rather leave time at the
end than in the beginning
so uh jim if you uh represent spelaine
if you could start with um
bringing scott mason executive
commissioner mason forward
director he's been promoted
you got your mason are you there sir
he's muted yeah i just asked on mute him
might not
be ready because there we go
executive director you available yes sir
can you hear me okay we can sir go ahead
if you wouldn't mind kicking it off
that i will it's um
i i do apologize this is our first time
working with the legislature on the zoom
format
it is a different format than what we're
used to with some of the zoom stuff
we've
done earlier in the year but uh
hopefully hopefully everybody okay
representative leflame i like the the
background that you have
thank you um so i would like to thank
you chairman lang and and all of the
committee members for attending today
my name is scott mason and i am the new
executive director of fish and game
and like um some of you this is my first
time going through the legislative
process in this role
and uh i'm looking forward to spending
this first year with you folks
mr executive you mind holding for one
second
any any member who has his mic um
unmuted could you please mute it during
the presentations it's a little bit
easier to hear so we don't any
background noise on what's going on and
then you'll be able to unmute yourself
when we get to the q a section thank you
go ahead and continue your executive
director thank you today i've asked
mark ellingwood chief of our game
division
to speak to you directly about the work
that he does
under the game division is also our
non-game
program and our habitat programs sheree
patterson
is the chief of our marine division
she'll speak on that
jason smith chief of our inland
fisheries division
this includes habitat biologists
and the hatchery program
colonel jordan will join us and he is
chief of our law enforcement division
and then commissioner chris hodgston
will speak on the role that the
commission plays with fish and game
and then um coming up i guess you you
know our final batter will be uh
paul sanderson he is our legal and
legislative coordinator he will lead
he'll lead our team through the
legislative process this year
he'll be giving you the highlights from
our other three divisions
public affairs the business division
and the engineering division and i'm
going to let mark sit in here
and he will give you his comments very
quickly uh mr chair it looks like a bull
khan may have joined as an
uh attendee instead of a panelist um
there's no last name but
i do recognize abul so i will be
promoting him to panelists
mr chair i also see uh representative
kittridge
uh listed as an attendee
mr chair this is mark ellingwood are you
ready for my presentation
both of them have been promoted just
give me one second so i can take care of
one
uh legislative issue uh representative
are you with us
he's muted yes i
am can you state where you are and
whether you're alone
uh mr chairman i'm in my home and i'm in
one room alone thank you very much and
representative mckittrich it seems like
you've joined us
can you tell us whether you're where you
are and whether you're with
alone or with somebody
representative you're muted
representative kittridge if you could
unmute you will
one more time representative uh getrich
are you with us
and can you tell us where you are and
whether you're alone or not
i'm at home i'm alone
thank you representative mckittrick uh
yep uh
represents executive director mason
again continue i apologize
thank you thank you very much uh
mr chairman uh this is mark ellingwood i
am
chief of the wildlife division i'm a
wildlife biologist who oversees the
wildlife group
we have 28 employees within the wildlife
division
the majority of whom are certified
wildlife biologists but we also have a
biometrician
a licensed surveyor and a
land agent our three primary
focuses are game management non-game and
threat endangered species
and habitat management the division
budget is
five and a half million dollars which is
roughly 16
of the total department budget funding
is very
diverse then from things such as
dedicated revenue associated with
permits
federal funds that are dedicated for
wildlife management
do we lose scott it looks like
jim represents splain if you can keep
attention to the
attendees list and add him back in when
he joins
looks like he dropped the call
so welcome to the world of zoom and
public meetings
yeah before this is kind of what it's
like here we go
okay this is mark ellingwood can you
confirm that you hear me
we can thank you very much
representative
um in terms of uh what we do our primary
focus is game management the setting of
seasons
the management of those species that
constitute game species within the state
that stems from everything from moose
deer beer and turkey
to waterfall on the coast of the state
and everything in between
in total we manage something on the
order of 30 species
these species are critically important
to uh both recreational and economic
interests of the state
not to mention the ecological values
that they represent to our citizenry
our non-gaming endangered species
program
focuses on 51 threatening endangered
species
but also includes a significant number
of species of greatest conservation need
and the mantra within the program is to
keep common species common
much of what that program does is
monitor and protect those species
protect critical habitats and provide
technical services to a diverse group of
people
and interests that uh share our values
regarding non-game species
our wildlife habitat program entails
both
the purchase and protection of critical
wildlife habitats
we have sixty thousand acres that we
actively manage
we have an additional twenty thousand
acres in easement
responsibilities relating to that work
include not only habitat management but
also
also infrastructure management and a
host of stewardship responsibilities
that accompanies
our ownership of those fast lands we
also are very vested in technical
outreach regarding forest management for
the good of wildlife in the state
we fund the wildlife extension
specialist at unh
and we are heavily vested in their
programs in a variety different ways
perhaps most notably we have a staff
member
up north fully committed to providing
technical services to industrial forest
land owners
and throughout the state we work with
landowners to help enhance wildlife
values of their property
we also are very vested in animal damage
control in the state we have dedicated
staff that do that work
we provide technical services and we
also provide uh
actual control options through permits
and we lend and provide
provisions that help with mitigation
such as fencing repellents and scare
devices
finally we have something we call the
conflict abatement team
a team of a half dozen biologists who
are trained in immobilization and
handling of wildlife and so they
constitute a
first response group in terms of a moose
on meetings and highways
deer in store fronts bears and backyards
and homes and so we have that skill set
as well
rather than speak further i'd simply say
that i've enjoyed my history and
interacting with your committee
i tend to be over there quite frequently
and i look forward to working with you
if you have any questions i'd be glad to
answer them
mr chair representative in the attendee
list and has been promoted to panelists
representative eagan if you could just
state where you are and whether you're
alone or not
if you're referencing me yes it's timmy
and
since i could not access the i just saw
the invite come in at 108 for the
private channel so i've been paying
attention since one o'clock my fault i
didn't see you on the list
get a heads up from somebody else and
representative can you tell us where you
are and whether you're alone or not
i am alone in my home in sugar hill
thank you very much
any questions for the marine wildlife
biologist
thank you very much thank you
scott who's up next
sorry mike and i are sharing a computer
she's been promoted to panelists
thank you shirt uh looking forward to
hearing your presentation go ahead and
begin
good afternoon mr chair and fish and
games
i'd like to thank you for the
opportunity to present the marine
division's
in the fish and game department we all
have our role to play the marine
fisheries division was responsible for
managing
and protecting the rich natural
resources and habitat
coastal waters harbors and customers
our financial footprint in the fishing
department encompasses six percent of
the history's budget
we have approximately 25 staff to
conduct a
variety of work we often work
inter-jurisdictionally with atlantic
state
uh atlantic coast state and federal
partners to manage
over 62 green species
that really know no political boundaries
providing scientific expertise and
stock assessments modifications to
fisheries management plan
for species such as northern shrimp
lobsters american people american
as well as their habitat we manage
fish passage systems for diagonals
and migrate between fresh water and
estrogen habitats
and we monitor
we have marketing programs that collect
abundant technological data on numerous
marine species
residing in or migrating from new
england waters
we monitor the catch and harvest of new
hampshire's commercial
and recreational cooking in tidal waters
and the division manages and develops
monitoring and sampling programs
recreational
as well as the commercial marines
and protection of their habitats
the marine division licenses and
monitored agricultural communities in
partnership
with the new hampshire department of
environmental services
in the department of health and human
services division of public health
the majority of our acquisition
licensees to date are for oysters
the marine division also oversees the
great bay national
estuarine research reserve um
only called this goodness where the
research programs
um out of giving focuses on
understanding the structure and
function of the great great ecosystem
and the effects of natural
human induced changes the reserves
research and monitoring efforts focus on
sports
water quality land use continued
biological community and climate change
um workshops are conjunction
through this program to give new
hampshire high school teachers
hands-on science technology curriculum
um through their learning programs
and bring technical information to
community planners
yes you know and local officials
with great bay watersheds so it's got a
wide reach to it the great bay discovery
center
hosts a variety of educational programs
throughout the year which are designed
to teach visitors about the unique
natural and cultural resources of the
great bay estuary
and on a typical year this includes over
11 000 visitors
of course that does not mean last year
or into this year
and students as well as
over five as i'm sorry 7 000
volunteer hours for the various programs
and
projects that they conduct they also
conduct modeling to evaluate the
resilience of salt marshes
that will rise across the country and
monitors
indicators useful usefulness to
assessing and tracking the health of
great bag
so as you can see we have a a large
footprint to be concerned about
thank you for this opportunity i
appreciate it
thank you mr patterson is there any
questions for
the marine division
there being none thank you miss madison
for joining our group and scott who's up
next
next up we have jason smith chief of our
inland fisheries division
representative's plane to see if we can
find him if he's over in uh
he's been promoted thank you mr smith go
ahead and
begin when you're ready
jason you're still on music
chase if you can unmute yourself that
would be helpful yeah okay i will start
over
sorry about that
all right um what i've previously said
was my name is jason smith i'm currently
the
chief of the inland fisheries division
our division is comprised of
approximately 40 employees
28 of which work in our state hatchery
systems
and similar to what uh my predecessors
in this meeting spoke to we do very
similar things as far as species
monitoring and habitat protection
but on the freshwater resource side of
things
our division is comprised of six primary
focal areas
we have a cold water fisheries program
which is primarily focused on clean
water species such as brook brown
rainbow trout
we do a lot of research work movement
and habitat use and how to protect those
areas
next we have a warm water program
which administers over 500 bass
tournaments on annual basis
we also work with cool water species
such as walleye and northern pike
uh we also work with the new hampshire
athletics association
and a new program out there we're trying
to get kids involved in fishing
so we work with all the high schools in
new hampshire that are interested in
having
uh competitive fishing tournaments our
next program
area is what we call our large lakes
program they're primarily focused on any
body of water
that's great in the 500 acres species
that we manage primarily in these large
water bodies and
involve landlocked salmon lake trout
rainbow trout
and to a large degree also rainbow smelt
which is the
the forage base in the uh
and the uh what drives the growth and
the health of these fish populations
we also have what we call a fish
conservation program
this program works with digest species
very similar what charis group does
we work on fish passages we work with uh
fish ladders to trump truck and trap
alewives and shad and try to restore
them we used to do a lot of work with
the restoration of atlantic salmon but
we also write
uh species recovery plans for
species the greatest conservation need
and our fifth program area is
what we call our fish habitat here we do
a lot of
technical sorry we give a lot of
technical
uh expertise on regards to stream
crossing and fish passage
we invest in land conservation projects
when we find
adequate quality fish habitat areas that
we want to protect
among amongst a lot of other things and
finally we have our
fish culture program many of you know
uh across the state we have six
state-owned and operated
trout and salmon hatcheries they're
located in berlin twin mountain
warren new hampton milford and our
partner mill hatchery in new derm
so with that i would entertain any
questions that you might have
thank you mr smith for that uh
presentation and thank you for the
hatcheries i've taken all for my kids to
almost
all of them at some point in time in
their life so uh they're excellent
little programs
there any questions from the um from the
committee
to uh talk to mr smith in charge of
inland fisheries
we have a raised hand uh representative
egan
yep go ahead representative and meet
yourself and go ahead
good afternoon will there be
any requests or bills filed to help the
hatcheries
we know that they've been asked in the
past of the legislature
do you see the concerns in any of the
hatchery development
that are going to need funding so i
you were broken up but i think i got the
gist of what you were asking
yeah one of our big challenges moving
forward as an agency is
our most of our hatcheries are near or
exceeding 100 years old
uh operating them in their core
current format and providing some
challenges to meet
modern water quality standards so in
order to continue to operate
the capacity that we're currently
operating we're going to need some
invest some significant capital into
some of these uh you will see that i've
submitted with the department a capital
budget request
that i'm hoping that if we need to talk
about its consideration
we can find time to do so but those are
the types of support that the hatchery
system
is going to need in order to you know
bridge this gap
thank you do you have a follow-up
looks like representatives all set any
other questions
for mr smith i'd like to ask when uh mr
sheriff it's okay
representative spelaine go ahead thank
you uh
mr smith given the the situation we're
in
um budget wise in the state ovid last
year and whatnot
how uh would you prioritize the fish
hatcheries over some of the other
uh budget areas that fish and game to be
uh looking to try to sustain
and uh how vital is it that those
issues get addressed this year versus
perhaps doing part of the year and part
of the next year i know we're going to
be going into a budget cycle and that
information might be helpful
so it it you know the data clearly
suggests that
you know stocking trout is a tremendous
revenue source for the department and
what's critical about this particular
revenue source it's what we call
unrestricted revenue
so a lot of our fishing license sales
goes to fund other parts of the agency
but as far as prioritizing any type of
immediate needs for infrastructure i
would say that
our current situation over at power mill
needs to be addressed
at the forefront
and we've had that fishery or fish
hatchery come before us before with
concerns so i can
understand that
thank you any other questions for mr
smith
i have a question representative howard
all right well you know i'm this is
really uh freezing up a lot on me
hopefully i'll hear his answer uh jason
i was just wondering do we have the
federal
discharge permit for the new durham
hatchery yet
so that permit went into effect on
january 1st
oh all right thank you
any other questions for mr smith
there being none looks like mr smith
you're off the hook uh
mr mason do we have the next person
director mason do we have next person up
uh colonel kevin jordan chief of our law
enforcement division
colonel jordan go ahead please jim is he
in our
scottish office thank you
colonel jordan if you're good go ahead
and begin that'd be great
you'll need to unmute kevin
kevin if you unmute you begin
good afternoon does that work you're
there sir
head colonel this this is an incredible
system i wish you all the best of luck
moving forward
uh in legislating with this with these
challenges chairman lang thank you for
having us on board i look forward to
meeting you and working with you um and
the rest of the committee i see a lot of
familiar faces and some that are new
i want to welcome you all aboard and
again i look forward to working with
each of you um we spend or i spend a lot
of time at the legislature
we we're in charge of laws in the state
um
and i'm very passionate about the laws
and the changes that come forth
uh because we worry about our
constituents and
and then i my main concerns with my
officers to make stuff that works
uh and the committee has been great to
work with for over 10 years now that
i've been there
so we're responsible for spending about
21 of fishing games budget we're a large
group with the largest division
within the agency uh i think it's
important to understand
today that we all work as one big family
over there
wildlife priorities the inland fisheries
priorities become the law enforcement
priorities
we're supported by a great business
division uh we work
hand-in-hand with the marine division
along our coastline
um so it's a very cohesive group and it
works it works tremendously well
together and you'll see that
uh hopefully even with this crazy
legislative session
so the law enforcement division does
everything that you would expect it to
do
hunters and fishermen we're looking for
compliance
uh voluntary compliance is the goal
actually for following the rules and
regulations and our bag limits
we work with the wildlife division to
maintain uh plans for future for
resources and habitats and we work to
make sure that
the general public understands that and
helps us to reach those goals
so we're also in charge of searching
for probably best known for so any event
that occurs off the highways in
in our woodlands or inland water ways
become our responsibility
that is a big draw on my officers and
our budget
and many here have heard us discussing
these issues that are raised
relating to search and rescue we conduct
about 180 missions
this year was a little higher because of
covid we had a lot more people in the
outdoors because that was
i think where people felt safer but
normally in a normal year we're up to
180 to 200 rescues a year
i have four of the best k-9 teams in the
state
by far they're called upon by all other
agencies
to help them because these dogs are
highly trained and do a great job
they assist us uh tremendously in search
and rescue
uh and that program has run completely
off of donations which we're pretty
proud of
um so the equipment and the dogs and all
the training is done
outside of state budgets which is
helpful
uh we have the the best underwater
uh sonar search equipment in the state
now
and i have a really top-notch team that
operates it um and so we have the
ability to
to search at great depths when we can't
get divers down
and to to conduct accurate and efficient
search missions this is used by marine
patrol during drowning recoveries when
we us
we assist in those uh endeavors which we
do
12 to 14 each year we're in charge of
all the ohrv
atv utv and snow machine
enforcement within the state that has
become that has grown
tremendously over the last few years
exploded really
in the north country those have present
some have presented challenges as we
have 42 field officers currently in the
field covering the entire state
and i just want to remind i like to
remind folks that the city of concord
has 80 police officers on its force
new hampshire fish and game has 42
covering the entire state as a
comparison
so these men and women are busy uh and
they
they work real hard to make sure that
they meet all of these priorities so we
enforce
uh speed limits and we do all the
accident investigation
all the violations and trail related uh
issues along with uh dncr
within the state that that comes under
our responsibility
um and we also run
a pretty successful television show if
you haven't seen it i encourage you to
watch northwoods law
it's a good example of what uh what our
staff
does on a daily basis uh and it'll give
you
some insight in some of the challenges
that we face and some of the limited
resources
that we work with and how well that all
goes so
we're very proud of what we do we're
very passionate about it
we feel it's vital to the state and to
its citizenship
and we look forward to working with you
to protect that moving forward
um that is really a thousand foot view
but i wanted to keep it as short as i
could and and i certainly
i'm going to answer any questions anyone
might have
thank you kurt jordan and thank you for
that uh introduction
um are there any questions from the
committee uh for colonel jordan
mr chair i'm seeing a hand raised from a
grace hodgdon in the attendees list
i don't know if you want to allow
questions from the public at this time
or not
yeah what are you on muter jim don't
promote her just unmute her
representative spelaine
and we'll let her ask her a question
hey good good afternoon everybody this
is chris hodge and uh the commissioner
from merrimack county i was just simply
raising my hand to
note that i uh was ready to go next
well then stay right there uh
commissioner and well
as soon as the colonel's done we'll have
scott introduce you
i'll anybody else have any questions for
colonel jordan
colonel jordan it looks like you're off
the hook have a great day
thank you sir and scott if you could
introduce your next uh
speaker next up we have commissioner
chris hodgson
uh he is going to be speaking on the
role of the fish and game commission
[Applause]
commissioner hodgson go ahead please
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
hi ginger excellent uh so thank you for
your time thank you to all members of
the committee for
this opportunity i i wanted to uh just
provide a bit of information about the
commission's composition
how we're structured and then a little
bit more detail on our duties and role
and support in the department so in
terms of our
composition how we're structured we have
11 members
one from each of the counties so we're
geographically diverse
we have one member from the seacoast
those are the communities that
touch our seacoast or great bay and uh
all of our terms are for five years
occasionally they are shorter because
they're filling an unexpired term
we all of us go through the governor and
council
process for appointment and annually
we elect a chair a vice chair
and a secretary treasurer to lead us
we principally conduct our
work inside our committees inside our
full commission meetings
we meet monthly as a full commission we
have
approximately eight committees
that are all comprised members of the
commission several of those
are interagency committees
they include the lakes advisory
committee the
rivers advisory committee both of those
being
also going through the governor and
council process
and then we have a commissioner who's
liaison to the marine
advisory committee so really a lot of
our what in some respects makes the
commission and the department unique i
think is the extent to which we have
just a very large amount of opportunity
for public input through our monthly
meetings
our committee meetings and then the
other interagency committees that we
participate in as commissioners
with respect to our our duties and our
roles
if you were to look through the fish and
game statute
virtually entire statute and one way or
the other defines what we do as a
commission
but really i'd focus on
206 4a which is the most
general statement of our duties and and
um
those really aren't i think all of us
take to heart
the fact that our duties are to be
stewards for our state's
wildlife and lands be represent
citizens representatives on these issues
and also to set general policy
for the department and then in with
respect to
general policy the statute goes on to
define
uh four more specific elements and those
are the conservation and protection
management of our wildlife populations
and habitats
where our duties include the development
funding and implementation of a
long-range strategic plan
the acquisition development and
maintenance of public access
to our lands and waters public education
and the building of
support among the public for our our
efforts
and then we also establish policy
positions on
legislative issues that come before your
committee in the legislature that affect
our fish wildlife and marine resources
and the overall management of the
department and i'm often asked you know
that the
duties of the commission are really well
articulated in the statute
but constituents often ask how we make
our decisions and the commission's done
a fair amount of work developing what i
call a decision
making matrix within which our we
consider all the issues that come before
us and
and those really are encompass
five different elements uh we consider
the biological impacts and of a
recommendation
we consider the financial implications
and constraints
of proposal or policy the legal
considerations and their ramifications
the technical feasibility
is an important element there are a lot
of great ideas but
being certain that we can technically
accomplish them is important and then
another great consideration in our work
is the social and political aspects of
it we
we need to take seriously the part of
our duties that call on us to build
public support and
acceptance for what the department's
doing um
we also have a rulemaking role
that is varied there are 20 some
sub-sections to the department's rules
and and really
uh if you were to narrow in on where the
commission has the
largest role it's in the the wildlife
seasons fishing licensure and education
rules that be 300 400 1100 and 1200 and
then
elements of the marine and
importation and possession rules also
have
commission engagement uh we
frequently participate in the public
hearings that the department
uh conducts review public comment and
then uh of course at our meetings
deliberate on and either adopt or
consider rule proposals before it moves
on to the jail car
process part of our role is also
the approval or consent for the
expenditure of certain funds
these are principally funds that are
derived through the licensing process we
have a wildlife
habitat fisheries habitat game
management
fund um i think probably being the
largest ones
we also uh accept and
um allocate uh at the
s at the um advisement of the staff
donations to the department i really
think that's one of the most
extraordinary aspects of the fish and
game department
we routinely see um dozens of
individuals in a given month make
donations
to the mission of the department which
is i think it's really extraordinary
when you consider uh people donating
their hard earned money to
the mission of a government agency it's
not a it's not the most common of
occurrences
and then lastly constituent service you
know in addition to just public
engagement
uh we field a wide variety of
inquiries from the public both
inquiries related to policies but just
also
inquiries related to education and
information
and uh you know they really run the
gamut of everything
from uh what do i do with a fox under my
porch to
can you help me with a alteration of
terrain
uh application that i have have pending
and uh it's uh
it's so it's really a varied uh set of
issues that come up before the
commission
and uh i think a tremendously enjoyable
and
and uh fascinating experience for all of
us
so thank you mr chairman for your time
happy to uh
to answer any questions that you may
have and um look forward to working with
you during the session
thank you commissioner option are there
any questions from the committee for
commissioner hodgson
the sound of silence is deafening
commissioner so i think you're free to
go
thank you sir
director mason do we have anybody else
uh lined up here
uh yeah uh paul anderson is our legal
and legislative coordinator and he'll be
finishing up uh for us and he will be
explaining
the roles of the other three divisions
here at fishing game public affairs
business division and the engineering
division
he has been promoted mr chair thank you
representative
mr sanderson are you with us please
you'll need to meet yourself if you
haven't done that already
there we go i think that did that
achieve it it did sir good
okay thank you um i'm here to speak with
you as the legal and legislative
coordinator or a member of the
director's office
uh to talk to you about the remaining
three divisions of our department
and it is not because they are by any
means less important because that
certainly isn't the case
the first one i wanted to describe to
you is the business division
uh because they are responsible for
achieving the collection of revenue in
our department
they do that through operation of the
licensing system
where they sell hunting fishing and
trapping licenses
that's done both in person and also
online
they are responsible for operating the
system used to register
snowmobiles and all off highway vehicles
ohrv
machines with all of this information
that's collected and all of the revenue
that is collected through this various
licensing
operation they also support the work of
the law enforcement division
by providing up-to-date information on
the status of licensees and registrants
that's used in the field by the law
enforcement division
to determine if violations have occurred
they also support the work of the
critically important federal aid
coordinator in the collection of funds
from various federal agencies
where we receive revenue by means of
grant
so after we have all of our revenue
collected they account for
the how this is dealt with in our
various specialized
and dedicated funds unlike other
agencies we have
the fish and game fund which is not a
general revenue fund
general fund uh revenue it is
specialized and dedicated to the work of
the fish and game department
and they also manage a total of 16 other
dedicated and specialized funds some of
those were described to you by
commissioner hodgson
they also handle all of our accounts
payable and disbursement operations
they support the staff and
administrators of each one of our
divisions
by assuring that all of the obligations
of the department are properly
documented
and paid in accordance with requirements
of both federal agencies and the state
department of administrative services
as part of this all contracts
requisitions
governor and council and fiscal
committee items are processed in that
division
after all of this work of receiving
money and paying money is done they
create periodic financial reports on
both revenue and disbursements
for both internal purposes and also by
use of all external parties
including the department of
administrative services
and the legislature this being a budget
year
the business division is responsible for
the preparation of all required
state operating and capital budgeting
requests for the department
and it is their staff that responds to
questions received
whether it be from the governor's office
the department of administrative
services or any responsible legislative
committee they are responsible
uh for determining after money has been
spent auditing support
they provide staff and information when
auditors are assigned
to look at either financial transactions
or when the legislative budget
assistance sends over
a request for a performance audit from
the legislature
and then finally they are responsible to
procure
maintain and ultimately dispose of over
vehicles that go on the road as well as
all of the boats snowmobiles
trailers ohrvs and pieces of heavy
equipment
that are used in the operations of the
department
so as you can see they provide a very
important back office support element to
all of the divisions of our department
from there i want to move on to our
facilities and lands divisions
it would probably surprise many of you
to know that the department manages
or owns more than 160 buildings
135 boat ramps 130 dams
seven fish ladders and over 80 000
acres of wildlife management areas
conservation easements and other
interests
our facilities and lands division
works to complete the maintenance on all
of these
properties as much as possible using our
own forces
but when necessary they have access to
specialty subcontractors and
professional engineering services
they do this with a very small staff
including the public works manager
the public boat access program
coordinator one land agent
one engineering technician small
construction crews
and a grounds foreman the boat access
construction
and maintenance duty of this division
handles all of these ramps
uh that includes not only designing and
constructing those that may be new
but also keeping those that have been in
place for a period of years
maintained and in operation on the 160
buildings that we have
they do everything ranging from routine
light maintenance
all the way to full office renovations
and roof replacements
they design and plan also for energy use
management and conservation and the
operation of all of our facilities as
required by law
and then land management is done using a
team
that involves representation from all of
our divisions
to try to determine the appropriate way
to manage and use
all of the lands that we have i wanted
to end
with the public affairs division
primarily because
we've spent these last few minutes
giving you a huge amount of information
which i'm sure is hard to retain and
hard to remember
so therefore what i want to do is is
part of the public affairs division to
say they're the people that operate our
website
which is found at wildlife.state.nh.us
or you can find it using a state agency
link through the state website
and that's where you're going to find
more information about any of the issues
that we've talked about today
as well as many more but in the public
affairs division it isn't just the
website
uh they also have an information unit
that is involved in marketing
promotion of all of our programs
including merchandising and advertising
they are the ones that provide public
information notices
and manage media relations and that
includes
social media broadcast media event
management
the creation of our publications and
also relationship with landowners
which is a program we have to maintain
properties as being
open to hunting fishing and trapping by
solving
difficulties that landowners may have
within with how their land is to be used
that division also operates the
education program
which includes not only voluntary uh
conservation education
matters aquatic resources education but
also
statutorily required hunter and trapper
education courses
some examples of the more voluntary
courses are
trout in the classroom program the
watershed education program
the watershed ecology institute the
let's go fishing
program becoming an outdoors woman
program
wonders of wildlife program for grade
school children
and the urban wildlife program that is a
partnership
with the new hampshire audubon
massabesic with the manchester
schools and project wild which is a
teacher-based
wildlife curriculum in order to
accomplish these educational objectives
we operate the owl brook hunter
education center
which is up in holderness we operate a
summer camp for children called berry
conservation camp
there is a discovery room at our
headquarters building
which hopefully at the end of covid will
be back again open for people to be able
to see and use
as well as visitor centers at two of the
state
fish hatcheries again we've given you an
awful lot
there is a lot to read that is on our
website if you have any particular
questions or interest in any of the
things that we've described to you
but other than that i'll be happy to
answer any of your questions
and say that i'm the one that primarily
will be talking to you as you start
considering bills
thank you very much
thank you paul appreciate it does
anybody have any questions for
uh mr sanderson
i would like to ask uh paul if he wanted
make uh contact information available to
all of the reps while he's here because
he is a fantastic resource for directors
from us
sure i'd be happy to for all of you as
representatives you can reach me
by email and that is paul.sanderson
at wildlife.nh.gov
and you can also call my phone number my
direct line at the department
is 271-1136
on days like today when i'm operating
remotely that rings directly on my cell
phone so in fact i'm available to answer
any questions that you might have
so whether it is by an email
communication or telephone communication
not only to me but anyone else if we can
provide help and assistance to you we'd
be glad to do it
mr chair representative harvey has her
hand up
thank you representative harvey gary
with your question
thank you mr chairman i have a question
for the department in general and i
didn't know if you were going to have an
open question and answer for the whole
department it's not necessarily a
question for
mr sanderson specifically so let's
finish up with paul and then we'll jump
back to your questions anybody else have
a question directly from mrs sanderson
representative ellis will you raise your
hand
yes i would like him to repeat his uh
email address
sure be glad to do that it is paul
p-a-u-l dot sanderson
s-a-n-d-e-r-s-o-n
at wildlife.nh.gov
okay thank you sure
anything else for mr sanderson
there being nothing we're gonna jump
back to mr mason
and we can go back to uh representative
harvey if you have your question you can
ask and scott can get us to the right
person answered or answer the question
himself
thank you so um it may not be a question
that is answered today um but at some
point
and and maybe it's a private question i
don't know if there's another interest
in this or not but at some point i'd
like to know more about the 20 by 20
project and new hampshire thinking
game's role
with that project
scott do you want to answer that or do
you want to take it offline and you can
answer representative harvey through an
email
um we'll take it offline and represent
it and
answer through an email um thank you
if you just distribute that to the
entire committee so everyone understands
what that 20 by 20 program is
i'd be happy to thank you sir once again
i would like to thank everybody
thank everybody for the opportunity for
us to participate with you folks today
i think it's a good learning learning
experience for us
so don't go anywhere yet scott cause i'm
gonna open it up for anybody else who
has questions of the department in
general
based on everything we just heard and
hopefully you can either answer it or
get us to the right person so does
anybody else have
questions from the committee um for the
fish and game department in general
and scott will get us to the right
person or take the question offline and
get an answer to you
ah scott you got off uh scot-free rep no
representative eagan just raised his
hand
mr chair yeah
you'll need to mute yourself
representative eaton there you go
my internet's a little slow so
everything's delayed commissioner nice
nice to speak with you again could you
share with us what you think
your one pressing issue is for the
coming year or two
that the committee can be supportive to
the agency
with help
um representative egan was asking what's
our one
pressing issue um
i'm not one thing i've learned in the
last six months there's no such thing as
the one
pressing issue overall the one
issue that that impacts us almost in
everything we do
obviously is funding and budgeting um
anything we could do to change that is
is something that
that is certainly of interest to the
department
thank you thank you
mr chair i've got a question up one
second
jim representative vegan do you have a
follow-up at all are you all set
okay representative spelaine go ahead
thank you uh mr chair uh mr mason uh
your
predecessor as director had um
put in a bill through the senate that
allowed him to be the
sole decider or the department to be the
sole decider of their rates and fees
uh at that time a lot of the rates and
fees
were raised um out of state not much as
in state
do you have any intention to evaluate
the current rates and fees being charged
and look at parity
out of state hunting uh in new hampshire
with
argan at the moment versus the
surrounding states and um
address any of that since you're talking
about budgeting
um this year we are not that would be
something we'd probably be looking at in
the future
thank you sir any further questions for
director mason
not hearing any not seeing anybody raise
their hands or try to get our attention
scott thank you very much for the
presentations for all your members
um i'm sure we look forward to seeing
you
uh in the coming months
thank you all once
mr again may i recommend that since we
are running ahead of schedule
that we take a five-minute break mostly
because i cannot type and go to the
restroom at the same time
sure we'll take a quick five-minute bio
break guys getting
run off and take care of things we'll be
back at
uh 2 11.
mr chair would you like me to keep miss
director mason
as panelist or come back to attendee
you can leave this panelist right now in
case something comes up in a couple of
things we're going to be talking about
next
um and then like i said everybody just
mute themselves and turn the video off
and off do your errands and then
come back in a couple of minutes and
we'll pick this back up
um
all right welcome back everybody we'll
wait till we see some smiling faces on
the cameras here
and we'll get started we have to smile
yes
it's a thursday we all get to hang out
together it's a great reason to be
smiling
[Music]
i have to respect my chair personally
so if we're waiting on anybody else
representing the wolf there's mr
representative flam looking for
kevin representative craig and jen to
come back
and represent oxel
he has representative voxel
representative harvey is missing
although she has a nice lamp it looks
like i think that's what that is
i think i'm here
[Music]
i just put down the phone
all right so jump back in um
um i just want to talk about
bills public hearings work sessions
executive sessions and if you need
caucuses
um and then we'll do a little quick
introduction members for people
especially our freshmen the legislature
and mutual legislature
hear from them and introduce everybody
around let's jump into the discussion
about the committee moving forward and
what things will look like
um so far we've only been assigned six
bills
which means we'll have a pretty quick
day a pretty quick um
legislative session as it relates to the
fishing game committee
um we've been asked uh to have uh full
committee days
so starting at 9am and going through
um five o'clock um to try to heal the
bills and get them
through so that we're not um wasting
time and
and putting putting bills off longer to
be hurt if we get them in
quicker and through this session um
one of the things we will be doing is um
i i had to try to do what's somebody's
in law enforcement they call it a cattle
called a court which allows me to
schedule all meetings at
km and then take them up as they come up
um
in an effort to be efficient because i'm
sure as uh the returning members know
sometimes you
schedule a kitty hearing for a half hour
and it takes five minutes
sometimes you schedule a midi hearing
for a half hour and it takes three hours
um and so an effort to try to
accommodate some of that and not
dead time or where uh a 30-minute block
of time
um 10-minute hearing um
i wanted to put up all 10 o'clock but
leadership is to know i'm not allowed to
do that
so we'll be scheduling all the bills
about in about 15 minutes the 20 uh 30
minute increments
uh so that we can short that window and
as built with some may be running late
because we're
bills take longer and some will come up
as soon as the clock ticks but we're
trying to reduce the amount of dead time
or
dead air time in the committee where
we're waiting for
just clock date a certain number so we
can start up a um
session or a public hearing so we're
going to try and reduce that so we don't
have as much waiting around time it can
be efficient
um but we have six bills in in
in uh currently assigned when i spoke to
leadership last night this
thing's office they still had four bills
left to withstand the committees at that
point
um so i don't know if any of those are
fishing game we may pick up a couple
letters
oh in the senate i believe only two or
three bills so
from march we should all expect a couple
bills coming over from the set
um so we should have a pretty short
um section uh my guess is we'll have
possibly just one day of public hearing
and then in the morning we'll we'll pick
another day and do a morning of work
session and just run through the bills
to make
our any amendments any changes we can
have that all lined up
and then use the break between the work
session and the executive session in the
afternoon
to get any amendments written i
understand ols is going to have a new
process for amendments
um so as we move from the public section
public hearing
to the work session actually i'm going
to go back to the public hearing as
we're talking the public hearing
um all it'll be a hybrid model so
members can either attend by video or
attend
in the room all of the room
sanitizing equipment has been delivered
to the state house
so we have new devices that will be in
each committee room
that will circulate the year five times
every hour which is significantly
greater than what the cdc recommends
for interior room like that um
the cdc requirement is two to two and a
half times so we'll be doing five
nearly or double um
so that uh so so if people want to
attend anderson they'll be welcome to
attend in person the rooms
they'll be my understanding will be
doubled in south so conditions will
be opening up and open up the doors and
people will be socially distancing just
out as far as it will be
um and again we'll have seating set up
but if you want to push
further i'll have no objection to that
um if you want to attend otherwise
you're going to attend the public
hearing by
uh remote and that's acceptable as well
um
if you happen to be in the ob um
for your um this is more about
representatives who have bills and other
committees if you're in the lob your
bill is going to be heard in another
committee you'll be allowed to testify
in person as a representative because
you're in the building
if you're a member of the public public
will be testifying remotely
um and there'll be no public access to
the building
the one exception to that rule will be
if we have uh if or paul sanderson the
legislative
gentleman and colonel jordan as a lead
of those department heads
um if they're in the building they're
going to be allowed to testify in person
especially if they've gotten up there
for
six bills who are hearing six bills and
testifying all six of them they'll be
allowed to present in person as well
um moving it over into more sessions
again mls is going to put on
um they're going to have a slightly
different process for uh uh
amendments uh bills so if we go into
work session into the work session we
find the bill has met but it needs a
couple of technical corrections
mechanical corrections
uh or or just a a change to it
we can email right in the committee room
the amendment over ols
they will process it and then have
somebody hand deliver the amendment back
to us in our committee room for
for the um executive session let's go
again
yes representative flame has his hand
yep let me let me just run through it
all then i'll open up a discussion
um i just want to run through the the
list of more sessions executive sessions
um but my goal would be i think with six
bills to do a work session in the
morning
work through any issues um unless we
decide
when we're in public hearing that it
needs a subcommittee and then we'll
assign a subcommittee
but um right now it looks like we're
we'll just go into work sessions in the
morning uh for one day
and then that afternoon we'll do the um
executive sessions for those bills or it
looks like maybe two days
of agile testimony or actual
legislative when the committee um if we
caucuses any time
um you know either in the work session
or in the uh
executive session the um you're welcome
to call it
we can just do like we just did a
five-minute reset so we're gonna turn
their cameras off and you can arrange a
as a caucusly a different way of uh
handling that caucus whether it be a
private zoo
meeting or a phone call or whatever you
want to manage
as a party as a party issue
um other than that uh i will
open up for questions in conversation
so jim representative explain who wasn't
had their hand up
representative laflame has his hand up
claim
your head thank you and uh good
afternoon
um i i
you're very loud uh representative lang
but for some reason
i'm missing some of the things
my question is um testifying in person
as a representative is that on bills
that you are a sponsor of or is that on
any bill you want to testify on
i was unsure about that or is it just
bills that you are sponsoring
ask a clarifying question on that with
with leadership but the answer they gave
the statement they made me made was that
if you're in the building and need to
testify on a bill you'll be able to
testify in person
um i i i presume that meant if you were
a sponsor co-sponsor but it's also kind
of awkward to be sitting in the fish and
game committee
room and and for whatever reason and
having to testify by remote into another
office
uh that's going on so um i i will bring
that to leadership
and when we come back for our first
meeting or i'll email the committee the
answer to that question
thank you i may have more questions
later
the next person goes mr chair
representative shirtless is raising his
hand
you had representative shirtless thank
you mr chairman
i had a question asking you the other
day from the new hampshire autobahn
and i wanted to know if the blue slips
would be available
for uh individuals
so we're still working on a solution for
blue sheets and pink cards
do said it has come up with a model and
i it's going to be reviewed tomorrow i
think
precision on how they're managing their
senate hearings but yes we will have
opportunity for
a cheat the equivalent of the blue sheet
and call the pink card
hearings thank you mr jim
any other questions in general about uh
bills public hearings work students
executive sessions or caucuses
representatives have another question
thank you i can't be the only person
with questions
i i i have the distinct
feeling from speaking to other people
that the
house leadership has given a lot of
gratitude
to the committee chairman to run the
committees
in the way that they see fit and i think
that's great
um will you be requiring
representatives at the in person
at the committee hearings and committee
meetings to have a face covering
so the last again the last thing i heard
on this topic was that if you're up
it's going to take a similar to a
restaurant approach if you're up and
moving around you're going to be
required to have a face mask on if
you're sitting in your seat and you're
socially distancing you can take your
face mask off
okay and i guess since nobody else
has any questions um
parking uh we're gonna be parking like a
regular
place in the store street um i assume
that we're still gonna be able to use
our old permits
um some of us did not practice store
street
in the calendar this week tim i believe
it was going in the calendar this week
the issues the parking and the clerk
mail out the appropriate passes so you
park at the store street garage you get
a little
like green or yellow or whatever the
color is there are they're picking this
year
um you're gonna pass for the store
streak or as well
thank you very much mr chair uh
representative craig has a question with
his hand up
craig go ahead hi thanks i may have
missed it but
have we settled on a day of the week for
committee hearings
i'm hoping to have the answer tomorrow
as to what day of the week the committee
hearing will be
um they have not given me a dis uh
speaker yesterday for that
and they said we're gonna finalize that
um this week
by friday and so i'm hoping tomorrow
when i'm in my
chairs vice chair meeting they will give
me an answer to that question
and i'll throw that answer out to
everybody else once i once i know what
day we'll be meeting there are no
further questions at the moment but
representative you had your hand up
briefly are you all set now
i have a question
pray because i have inadequate
connection here
can you hear me i can't remember
so this this is my first couple of
one because i only got about 25 percent
of these presentations
uh i am a returning member so i've heard
him before but
are we going to get a hard copy of the
presentation
and the second question is uh can you
send out an
email just laying out the procedures
that you're talking about because i'm
only catching
there thank you so absolutely i'll send
an email out after the chairs
vice chairs meeting which they're
supposed to lock it down i just saw we i
got my first notice of a public hearing
for a house bill senate bill 2 will be
heard next friday
um so in the election lawmany so they
i will send out uh after i speak with
the leadership in that chairs and vice
chairs meeting tomorrow austin
updated the email i do know we won't
have our first committee hearing
obviously until after the 25th
will probably be noticed in the calendar
next week
with a date and for the public hearings
so
um but i know that we're not going to
start hearings at least until
january 5th
i'm sorry you were cut out there
i'll intend to
she said she's going to send her notes
out after the meeting thank you very
much
uh mr chair you have two hands being
raised uh representative harvey was
first followed by your vice chair
representative khan
so representative
yourself ma'am
sorry uh you actually answered my
question that there will not be a
knitting meeting until after the 25th um
i was just going to remind you that some
there are people that work on the
committee and they need more than a
week's notice to get a day off from work
but
if it's not till after the 25th we're
okay thank you for
preempting my question um
and roberto's playing with the other
person uh
sir
representative john your video went away
and you are still muted
perhaps
representative howard you have a
question
are we going to get five copies of the
presentation
uh the official game put on first
i will speak to um commissioner mason
but the reality is i think
almost all the information they gave us
is on their website
uh it was just organizational and fish
about them which
are and who i'll ask him for the uh
summary presentation and see if he can
submit that to the rest of the
commission
mr chair uh representative khan is back
as a question awesome
okay uh
there we go sir
nope you've muted yourself again yeah
there you go in order
representative khan you just re-muted
again i don't know why your system keeps
muting itself
you seem to be having audio trouble
because you're still muted and every
time you've unmuted it's gone back
we can't hear you representative
is this something that could be
submitted by an email
i believe he's frozen
come back i'll reach out to him after
the meeting and and see what his
question was
anything else for um any questions
so does it take away going to find out
about
co-sponsors versus just someone wants to
testify
in the building already so you have to
be in there for a purpose you can't just
show up to justify you have to be in for
another reason
but find out if you can testify in other
communities
um i will also send an email to the
entire
committee on more information on public
hearing work sessions
and executive sessions and the
requirements of those
um i think that was like takeaways
um anything else and i'll get the
presentation
from uh scott mason um
and send that out to the entire media as
well if you get something up for that
so let's real quick we'll just do a
quick round of introductions so
we didn't do that in the beginning you
just introduced all different members
um so why don't we work in reverse order
uh representative three so start the
abominable list that we use roll call
and work
backwards
you are kind of chopping representative
reed
representative
could everyone mute until representative
reed calls your name please
so my name is ellen reed this is
i'm entering my fifth year on this
committee and
uh it was not a committee i initially
requested but i am very happy to be on
this committee
i don't think i'm speaking out of turn
to say
that i have a reputation for being one
of the more
vocal pro-conservation advocates on the
committee
my personal background i have in biology
i can't i fish but i wouldn't consider
myself an outdoors person but i am an
equestrian i do trail ride
and i also want to say that i've so
appreciated the work of the department
over the years
as i've served on this committee that's
about all i have to say
um
hi everyone ariel oxel i represent
um stratford county 15 which is dover
ward 3
which happens to be this section of
dover
south dover that is on little bay and
great bay
as well as two two of the rivers the
bellamy
and the chico that go into the bay as
well
i went to university of new hampshire
while i did not
receive a bachelor of science i did take
some electives in
oceanography and environmental
classes so this is of great interest to
me
i grew up in new hampshire and this is
obviously my first term and
i'm very excited to be here thank you
thank you representative ellis
rochester and uh
this is my
time for running and i was on
environmental and agriculture
and two uh special
two uh questions and now i'm
on this one and i'm
kind of relieved to be honest it sounds
like an exciting
thing aspect of it
and that's that's it i'm getting a lot
of feedback if they can hear my voice
i will just remind everybody as
representative said to please
mute yourself when others are speaking
um representative ellis were you done i
couldn't quite hear you
yes okay representative shirtless
all right steve shirtless this is my
ninth term in the new hampshire house
and when i came to the house in 2004 an
old time legislator told me
there were two great committees in the
new hampshire house fishing game and one
other
and if i i'll be done if i can remember
the other committee so i'm very glad to
be on this committee
thank you
thank you representative king
hi i'm mark king i represent ward 6
in nashua new hampshire
fish and game was my first choice three
or you know a couple terms ago and last
term
in this term i ran on supporting hunting
and fishing in our state
i ran on having a world where my
grandson
can grow up like i grew up where you can
hunt
you can fish you can be outside i'm a
second amendment guy
i care deeply about the environment and
i'm really proud to be on this committee
because i've seen this committee
over years work together
for what's best for our state and that
is the ultimate
of the ultimate importance i'm proud to
be with you all
thank you representative daughtonville
uh good afternoon roger dottonville
representing grafton 10.
the beautiful town of enfield the host
of moscoma
lake that now has a skating uh
track on it it's my third
term one fish and game i'm honored to be
in fish and game because i think it is
one of the few bipartisan committees in
the whole house
and it's great being able to work with
one another
and it's nice to be back thank you
thank you representative leflame
thank you um larry flam
i'm one of three members
in the house from uh co-wash district
three
which is the city of berlin um this will
be my third term
on the fish and game committee um it's
i've enjoyed i've certainly enjoyed my
time um
i think i've made friends
if you will on the committee um and
there have been some divisions in the
committee
um there have been some disagreements
but it was never
partisan um it was always bipartisan
and heaven knows you know like i said
has been disagreements
but it has not been a democrat or
republican thing
it's a it's a very bipartisan committee
and i enjoy um serving on it
thank you thank you representative egan
i believe i skipped you because i had
you added later
representative
representative reed i think i saw that
he left it looks like he's no longer in
the list representative reed
thank you very much representative
harvey oh
uh thank you um catherine harvey i
represent chester district one
this has been um this is my third term
on
fish and game and in the house it's
always been my first choice
um because um although i don't hunt fish
or trap
i certainly support our outdoors i do a
number of things outdoors
camping is a big thing with my husband
and me um as well
not this year but um as well as
kayaking and hiking and and and so forth
so
i support our outdoors um in whatever
way i can
i do support ethical hunting fishing and
trapping even though i just don't happen
to be one of those
thank you thank you representative smith
yeah hi my name is jonathan smith i
represent carroll county district five
i love everything outdoors hunting
fishing snowmobiling
dirt bikes you name it i'm outside i
manage a lot of land on my own that i
have
and i just care about the environment
but most of all i'm passionate about
liberty and freedom
of the citizens of this state thank you
thank you representative kittredge
please unmute yourself representative
you're still muted
representative kittridge
unfortunately i cannot unmute him for
him
that's fine representative dosty we'll
just go to representative kittridge when
he unmutes
good afternoon donald dusty i represent
dude
district one up in colebrook uh iatv ice
skater
and and certainly know that tourism is
so important to the north country
so that's why i got involved and
i don't hunt and fish but my
sons do and all of it's important uh
i get into it a lot to help make sure
that the atv and the tourism and the
locals
all find a way to get along we don't
want to lose
a single dollar in the north country as
everybody knows
in everybody's districts and uh and i
look forward to working with scott mason
and with all of you thank you thank you
representative
wolf uh representative reid
representative kittridge
was unmuted for a second oh
representative kitridge go ahead
hi i represent ward 5 in rochester
stratfor 12. this is my second term
i'm very interested in joining this
committee
i was formerly a municipal and county
things were less tranquil there
thank you
thank you representative wolf
representative wolf if you could unmute
yourself please
representative wolf you're muted we
can't hear you
okay representative wolf you're still
muted
there we go there we go we couldn't do
it off the picture
i'm dan wolf i represent merrimack 5
which is newberry in new london
i've been very involved and very
passionate towards maintaining
new hampshire's open spaces a wonderful
environment we have
somebody spoke about the tourism that's
cut that comes because of the
environment
um i manage a lot of land in the newbury
new london area
and have worked with fish and game and
with the
um search and rescue part of fish and
game
so i look forward to working with you um
after two years two terms on education i
understand this is a wonderful committee
where everybody gets along well so
i'm looking forward to that thank you
thank you representative love
hi i'm representative dave love i uh i
represent rockingham six which is derry
um my this is my second term my second
term on fish and game two
um you know uh the the outdoors is part
of who i am
i uh i i spent my summers in my
formative years on
on winnipesaukee and uh there isn't too
much too many parts of that lake that i
haven't wet a line
uh you know i i know that conservation
and uh
habitat uh preservation is uh is real
important to
you know all everything fish and game
and uh you know i i look forward to
helping the department uh you know
uh keep new hampshire in in real good
shape you know
i i like to remind people that um there
was a guy that
testified last year on a bill and uh and
he left us with with a a
a really really nice thing he said uh
new hampshire fishing game is the best
in the nation
don't mess it up and uh you know that
that's my uh
that that's that's what i want to do i
want to make sure we maintain the best
in the nation
and i look forward to doing that and
working with all of you
thanks thank you representative craig
hi sorry i missed out earlier
we were doing some cleaning around the
house and apparently either my modem or
router got unplugged and i had to go
reconnect to the
entire network so i am
kevin craig i represent coast district 4
which is the towns of lancaster where i
live
dalton and the unincorporated place of
kilkini
which is east of lancaster and consists
of
national forests this is my second term
in the house
a second term on fish and game i enjoyed
it very much last year
and i look forward to working with all
of those who are returning
and getting to know the newcomers to the
committee
i've spent a lifetime outdoors uh i
enjoy fishing
i theoretically hunt until it
comes time to get up and go and then i'm
like ron white it's really cold it's
really early and i don't want to go
but and i'm afraid i would actually uh
you know
catch a deer and then i would have to
process it and that's a lot of work
so uh i don't have
any ohrv's at the moment although i look
forward to
joining in that sport sometime in the
coming years assuming i ever have time
being semi-retired keeps me busier than
ever
so it's good to be back and good to see
all of you again
thank you representative
okay um did you i was expecting
representative howard to go next but i i
will do
i apologize representative howard
very few responses but uh anyways
i'm raymond howard i represent belmont
eight that's barnstead all in gillington
we're right here in the lower end of the
lake mississauga a great place to live
and uh i look forward to meeting all of
you in person
and hopefully be able to hear what
you're saying thank you
thank you representative howard
representative spelaine
hey i am uh representative james
spelaine i represent uh rockingham two
which is deerfield candia and nottingham
right here bear
by bear brook state park i actually live
not too far from bear brook state park i
could probably
uh throw a rock and hit it from here
um i am surrounded by about 200 acres of
mountainous terrain that i hunt and fish
more hunting than the fishing i
am on my fourth term and i've been on
fish and game every term so i'm on my
fourth term of fish and game as well i
started a charity for veterans on my
first term
in the new hampshire house and on fish
and game called the new hampshire
veteran sportsman foundation
and our aim is to give free hunting and
fishing licenses to any veteran in the
state that is in need
so that we can keep them outdoors and
getting
exercise and outdoor therapy
thank you thank you representative close
is representative i do not see
representative close on the line anymore
all right representative khan
representative khan you're having a mute
problem again
mr chair would you like to do your
introduction or
would you like to continue waiting for
representative
no i was going to give a minute but i'll
jump in and then if he works it out he
can jump in interrupt me
uh representative tim lang i'm in my
third term i've served
on the ways and means committee for two
terms election law for committee
as well last term i was a multi ran
multiple committees and then i also
served on job car in my this is my third
time on that committee as well
um i live in the lakes region i
service the towns of tilton and
sanderton up here at exit 20.
you hear me reference exit 20 because i
was originally born in new jersey and
everything is
relative to an exit number um so uh
so i'm off of exit 20 there i've lived
in new hampshire over
38 years now so more than half my life
is spent here in this state
we moved to the state because i grew up
as jim mentioned bear brook state park
when i was a kid and we lived in new
jersey every weekend we would come up to
bear brook and camp
and it got to the point where as soon as
i was out of school we'd come up and
camp
and my dad would go home on sundays and
leave my mom and the rest of us
nine kids up at bear brook state park to
spend the entire summer
at bear brook state park and he would
come up every weekend to visit with us
so
i've come to enjoy the outdoors a lot i
hunt i fish although i don't think i've
shot and i shot a deer in a long time
jim's gonna have to probably help me
with that one
um but uh i go out on a regular basis
with my children i have four kids
um they range in ages from 26 to 17.
and we still go out and fish out on a
boat and
hit our lakes and enjoy ourselves so i'm
looking forward to serving the committee
and and working with the committee to
pass the bills and move them forward and
um
i'm happy to uh reach out anybody can
reach out me anytime
and i i'm a tech guy so i tend to be up
really late at night not so much really
early in the morning
um so if you have a question at 10
o'clock at night feel free to text me
my cell phone number 603 566.
9802 one more time it's 603
566-9802
and feel free to text me at any time day
or night i'll answer it as fast as i can
i will just remind committee members um
if you're not going to make an executive
make sure you get to your party
leadership and let them know
so they're going to sign a replacement
for executive session
um and i guess that's it anything
else we want to cover in the committee
any other question
it looks like representative khan is
unmuted all right represent
you let's try it you know my name is abu
khan
i i represent seabrook and hampton falls
in district 20.
uh this is my fourth term serving and
the second time
in the efficient game committee i also
uh a member of the cebu board of
collectment for the
fifth term i am looking forward to
working all of you
in coming months also i am delighted to
see that our former speaker
in our committee thank you
thank you representative khan appreciate
that is there any
anything else that's come up since we've
uh we started anybody want to ask any
general questions if not
we'll actually be nine minutes early
before the end of the meeting
all right not seeing anything then we
will end this meeting i will send an
email
out with the answers to the questions we
have the takeaway items i have to answer
and i'll get that to all the committee
members and until then guys
look look check your email look for the
first hearing date which should be
sometime in the week of the 25th
thank you and i don't see that jen has
joined us again at this point
uh to end the meeting but i guess we
could all oh
she is she is here okay the whole time
oh okay
great all right bye guys
thank you